في المقابل قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي دميتري مدفيدف ان تدريب بريطانيا
لعسكريين اوكرانيين على اراض اوكرانيه
يدفع نحو حرب عالميه ثالثه واكد ان
المدربين العسكريين البريطانيين سيتحولون
الى اهداف مشروعه عند وصولهم كيف واشار
مدفيدف الى انه في حال تزويد كيف بصواريخ
تورس لضرب روسيا فان الهجوم على مصانع
انتاجها الالمانيه سيكون متوافقا مع
القانون الدولي
وينضم الان الينا من لندن مراسل الجزيره
محمد المدهون اهلا بك محمد حتى فقط نفهم
السياق الذي جاء فيه كل تصريح سواء لوزير
الدفاع او لمد فدف او ل رئيس الوزراء ريشي
سوناك يعني هل هل هناك شيء من التراجع لان
هكذا بد الامر بعد تصريح
مدفيدف جاء تصريح سوناك ليخفف من الموضوع
تفضل
ليلى هذه التاويلات بدات من التصريحات
التي ادلى بها وزير الدفاع البريطاني
جراند شابس لصحيفه سندي تيليغراف في
مقابله معها جاء عنوان المقابله في الصفحه
الاولى للتلغراف اليوم بان وزير الدفاع
سيرسل جنودا بريطانيين الى اوكرانيا وهذا
يوم مهم لانه اليوم الذي يفتتح فيه
المؤتمر السنوي لحزب المحافظين المؤتمر
الاول لهذا الحزب تحت قياده ريش السنك ورب
الاخير قبل الانتخابات العامه المقبله
لذلك اخذت هذه التصريحات كل هذه الاصداء
ولكن حقيقه ما قاله وزير الدفاع ان هناك
مقترحات افكار مستقبليه بشان نقل عمليات
التدريب التي موجوده الان في المملكه
المتحده على اراضي المملكه المتحده
تستضيفها بريطانيا وتشرف عليها وتنفذها
القوات المسلحه البريطانيه للالاف من
الجنود الاوكرانيين نحو 27000 جندي
اوكراني تخرجوا من هذه التدريبات ويتوقع
ان يرتفع العدد حسب وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه الى 3000 بنهايه هذا العام ان
تنتقل هذه التدريبات الى مكان قريب من
اوكرانيا او الى اوكرانيا نفسها وقد ناقش
هذا الامر حتى مع الرئيس الاوكراني نفسه
فلاديمير زيلينسكي عندما التقاه الاربعاء
الماضي في كيف وكذلك مع رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش والبحريه الملكيه البريطانيه وسلاح
الجو الملكي البريطاني فكره موجوده لم
ينفيها رئيس الوزراء لكنه قال انها فكره
مستقبليه ليس متعلقه بالحرب الحاليه وهي
جزء من الموائمه المستقبليه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه مع حلف شمال الاطلسيه
ان تكون هذه التدريبات موجوده على الارض
الاوكرانيه ولكن ايضا ليلى وزير الدفاع
دعى الشركات البريطانيه الدفاعيه المصنعه
للاسلحه للانتقال للعمل على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا امر لم نسمع تراجعا عنه
وذكر شركه بي اي اي سيستمز البريطانيه الم
صنعه للوزر وهي قد افتتحت كانت قد افتتحت
مكتبا لها خلال الاسابيع الماضيه في
اوكرانيا التوجه حاضر التوجه موجود ولكنه
مستقبلي وليس راهنا ومثل هذه الشعارات
الكبيره سنسمع كثيرا خلال هذه الايام ليلى
لان حزب المحافظين هو في مؤتمره هناك
الكثير من العناوين الناريه التي ستخرج من
هذا المؤتمر لان الحزب يريد الانتقال الى
مرحله الهجوم لانتخابات عامه قريبه ربما
مبكره سيدعو لها رئيس الوزراء الوزراء
ريشي سونك عندما يرى ان اللحظه السياسيه
ستكون مناسبه لذلك هناك تصريحات من قبيل
ايضا وزيره الداخليه ان تقول الغاء
اتفاقيه اللاجئين الخاصه بالامم المتحده
وما الى ذلك ولكن وزير الدفاع تحدث اليوم
في هذا المؤتمر كانت كلمته هي الكلمه
الاولى ل وزير مهم في مؤتمر حزب المحافظين
الذي يستمر اربعه ايام وقال ان الدعم
البريطاني لاوكرانيا سيستمر وان بوتن يجب
ان يهزم في هذه الحرب ولن يكتب له
الانتصار وان هذا الدعم يتكثف وسيزيد ايضا
اشكرك جزيلا
اذا محمد المدهون من لندن على كل هذه
المعلومات شكرا لك